we're losing our country down there
heated rhetoric on Capitol Hill as
Republicans make their first move in an
attempt to impeach the Secretary of
Homeland Security Alejandro mayorcas the
first Latino and immigrant in that
position we're going to impeach him he's
going to be impeached and he should be
he is the executive in charge of the
Border policy for for President Biden
Democrats say this is political theater
and that you can't impeach someone
because you disagree with their policy
it is now campaign season and
Republicans recently rolled out their
impeachment proceedings against
secretary like a pre-plan predetermined
political stunt it is the threshold for
impeachment is an official needs to be
found to have committed treason bribery
or high crimes and misdemeanors
Republicans have not offered any
evidence that he committed those crimes
and the witness Witnesses Wednesday did
not offer any proof the secretary's
abdicated His official duties he's in
dereliction of Duty and should be held
accountable they point to a record
number of migrants at the southern
border 250,000 people crossed into the
US in just the month of December
Republicans blame President Joe Biden's
policies for the influx I've seen lots
of reports about arguments about policy
I've seen nothing that rises the level
of an impeachable offense in the history
of the country only one Cabinet member
has ever been impeached Secretary of War
William bellnap for Brazen bribery in
1876 still even with a very slim
majority Republicans are hoping to make
history again and if not at least a few
headlines Patty Kaine Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
alzer